perhaps you're unfamiliar with the term
of knowledge graph
but
i suspect you have benefited from one
maybe even today
take your favorite virtual assistant did
you know that when you ask a question
like what is the capital of canada
the assistant is pulling the response
ottawa in this case from information in
a knowledge graph knowledge graphs can
be seen as a way of representing
semantic information between two
entities and what's really cool about
them is that modern applications allow
almost any entity you could imagine to
be described within one for example we
could have a knowledge graph of movies
and actors or we can describe
ingredients for recipes as well as the
steps required to cook them and this
means machines are able to understand
how these entities relate to each other
along with their shared attributes and
this allows us to draw connections
between different things in the world
around us now a knowledge graph is made
up of nodes
and
connected by edges
nodes describe any object or person or
place and an edge defines the
relationship between the nodes
so for example a node of ottawa
and a node
of canada
might be connected by the edge
of capital
and the thing here is that the pair of
nodes they can be connected by more than
one relation if the two are related in
multiple ways so for example let's take
another city let's take paris now paris
is the capital of
france
but it is also part of the roman empire
or it did used to be
so in this case the edges are paris to
france is capital
and then
paris to roman empire
is
city of
and we can see then how that these nodes
can be connected with multiple edges as
we expand this
and knowledge graphs can sort of build
different data sources and bind them
together to infer missing facts so let's
say you're trying to predict the number
of chinese restaurants in new york city
you could use one data source let's say
census data but that might not tell you
the whole story it might be out of date
it might not classify everything
correctly and so forth so if we add a
second data source like say online
reviews about all the different
restaurants and put them all in a
knowledge graph then we can use
statistical methods to infer that
actually there are 2 900 restaurants
serving chinese food in new york city
which may be a lot different than what
was reported in the census data alone
now knowledge graphs utilize something
called natural
language
processing
or
abbreviated to nlp
to construct a view of nodes and edges
through a process called semantic
enrichment i can take some unstructured
text say a white paper and classify that
text using natural language processing
to really sort of create data sets which
are correlated and
related to that information
and what that builds me is a knowledge
graph
and beyond sort of helping with question
and answer queries there are a lot of
other commercial applications for
knowledge graphs so for example the
recommended videos that are probably
appearing alongside this one in youtube
right now well they leverage a knowledge
graph based on queries people are
searching for and other videos that they
might enjoy
in insurance you can use knowledge
graphs to sort of and make sure that a
given claim for damage is actually a
true claim or whether it's been one
that's reported by a policy holder for
fraud and in retail knowledge graphs can
assist understanding the relationship
between products so that companies can
recommend different pairings that might
be of interest to customers
and i'll leave you here with some wisdom
that i was acutely aware of last night
and i'll share it in knowledge graph
form it consists of three nodes there's
human
then there is coffee
and then there is sleep
and these nodes are connected of course
by edges
the edge between human
and coffee is consume
the edge between
human and sleep is needs
and what i learned last night the edge
between coffee and sleep
is prevents
avoid caffeine after 5 pm folks
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe
thanks for watching